these children have survived a perilous
journey
they have made it to a camp in the
kurdish region of northern iraq
from mount sinjar where they were
besieged by islamists
they won't forget the experience
first we left everything behind and went
to the mountain
we left our house we found some trees to
rest under
we had no clothes to wear
we had nothing until we got here on the
way i saw many people who fell to the
ground
because they were thirsty some begged us
for some water to drink
but we had nothing
islamic state's sweep through northern
iraq has unleashed a massive
humanitarian crisis
over a million have fled the conflict
many
hundreds of thousands have fled to
iraq's kurdish region
the un says they are in dire need and so
many of them
are children we escaped from our
family's home
the village was a nice place and now
we're forced to be homeless here because
we left our homes behind
we didn't have any problems before our
house was nice
we never wanted to come here
germany britain and poland are among the
countries delivering aid to refugees in
northern iraq
the relief just barely helps them
survive
the children won't see their home again
until the islamists have been driven
away